Detective Danner:
Hit me with that Aniq sequel.
This is not a sequel.
Sounds like a sequel to me.
What was true in season one and
was again true this season is
that…
Ahhh!
There’s another murder.
(Gasp)
♪♪
We love murder.
-We’re drawn to it, one might
say.
-Mm-hmm.
What?!
We get a bunch of new suspects
and characters.
Look at all the people losing
their heads.
(Groans)
(Laughing)
All the casting is so on point.
Christopher Miller:
The person who was the killer, I
told them that they were the killer.
Everybody else I didn’t say one
way or the other.
Anna Konkle:
Every actor thought it was
themselves.
Elizabeth Perkins:
Because we’re so self-involved.
Yeah, we’re so self-involved.
Like, oh, please be me.
Ooh, I probably did it.
I did it!
I also killed Edgar!
I strangled him with my bare
hands!
He was poisoned.
I poisoned Edgar with my bare
hands!
By episode eight I was like I
know who did this.
I do know a suspect when I see
one.
Then when I got to find out who
did it, I was wrong.
This season, we decided to
really push the genres even
farther.
You’re waist deep in the same
dirty deal as your womb fruit.
Zach Woods:
It’s a fun challenge of the show
that you’re not just playing
a genre but you’re playing the
subjectivity of the person
whose episode it is.
You are madder than a mad hatter
at a hat haberdashery.
What-ho revelers!
It was maybe one of the most
magical acting moments of my
life.
Yes, John Cho.
I think people are going to fall
in love with these characters
while also getting to play that
game of whodunnit with
each other.
So...
Christopher Miller:
And cut!
I think we got it.
They’re always surprising you,
Lord and Miller.
And the stakes couldn’t be
higher.
(Cheering)
♪"It's my party"
By Lesley Gore♪
It’s everything you loved about
the first season and a bunch of
new stuff.
♪♪
Yeah!
Go! Go! Go!
♪♪
This is juicy!
♪You would cry too if it happened
to you. ♪
-Ahh!
-Ha ha!